COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I help some educators with
their TCP window sizes.
Will their networking
performance make the grade?
Stay tuned to find out.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC]
Tutorama is a platform,
which provides
crowdsourced instructional
videos to help teach people how
to do everything
from properly walking
a dog to filing their taxes.
In order to handle a massive
spike in video content,
they recently upgraded
their connection
between their on-prem setup
and Google Cloud Platform.
But despite their
fancy new connection,
their performance
didn't seem to improve
in the way they expected.
Running iPerf between
their local servers
and a GCP instance was only
getting about 1.1 megabits
a second.
Now we've already
seen that this is
way below what GCP can support
in terms of transport speeds.
So we went down the list,
checking their core account,
if they were using the
right IP, and what regions
they were optimizing for.
And by the way, if you want
to run those same tests,
check out the videos
linked in the description.
Sadly, none of these things had
an impact on their performance.
As such, I took this problem to
a few of our networking gurus.
And after some
thought and debate,
they all pointed me
in the same direction,
to something called
bandwidth delay product.
See, TCP protocol uses
specific window sizes
that define how
much data to send
between endpoints before
needing an acknowledgement.
When your endpoints are
physically close to each other,
this information can be
sending knowledge quickly.
But as that distance
increases, so does
the time it takes
for the destination
to acknowledge a window
of data, since we end up
getting capped by physics.
But here's the important part.
Any time an endpoint
is forced to wait
for an acknowledgement
of a packet,
it creates gaps
in the data flow,
which then limits the
performance of the connection.
As such, it's really important
to fine-tune the TCP window
size of a connection so that
either side doesn't end up
waiting for these situations.
Now to be fair,
most modern OSes do
a good job of auto-tuning
the TCP buffer sizes.
But in some cases, the default
values are still too small.
And as it turns out, the
Tutorama networking engineers
had already adjusted
these windows
based on their previous
connection speeds.
So to figure out how the
new setup was performing
by default, we set up a
test from their system
without any adjusted windows,
and saw a whopping 90 megabits
per second for
external IP access.
From there, we used a
few online calculators
to try to find better
values for the TCP windows.
But quite frankly, the
defaults for the TCP instances
produced the best results
for the Tutorama team.
At this point, the only
advice I could give them was
don't touch the defaults.
Now I don't say that very
often, but a 90x improvement
is really hard to beat.
If you'd like more
details on this problem,
check out the full article
in the description below.
And make sure to subscribe
to our Google Cloud YouTube
channel to get alerts when new
performance videos come out.
And don't forget, when
it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC]